as some of you know it's my 47th
birthday today and all I want for my
birthday is
a rescue mission to help this woman get
her kidnapped son back
someone messaged me and said that
Christian princess had posted a video
about a woman whose son had been
abducted there's a link to that video in
the description box in short a Christian
woman in Malawi got into a relationship
with a Muslim man when she was in
college they eventually had a son named
rayon and once they had a son the man
really dialed up the pressure on her to
convert to Islam side note I've heard
that story at least dozens of times if
not hundreds of times over the years
Christian woman Muslim man oh he's okay
with me being a Christian yeah until the
baby enters the picture and that's when
mom finds out that dad doesn't want any
Christian influences on his children so
he becomes obsessed with making her
convert in this case Roma she's the
mother refused to convert to Islam so
the Muslim father forged some paperwork
secretly got his son a passport and took
rayan to India Roma just went to work
one day came home and her son was gone
the father sent her a message and said
that he doesn't want his son to go to
hell so if she's not going to convert
she doesn't get her son
Roma's been fighting to get her son back
since the end of 2021 so it's been over
a year India won't take custody of her
son and send him home unless she takes
the case to court in India she can't
afford to do that her ex knows she can't
afford to do that which is why he took
ran and fled to India so he thinks he's
won and there's nothing she can do
pretty hopeless situation right
wrong because we're going to send Roma
on a rescue mission to get her son back
she's already in contact with lawyers in
India and she's ready to fight this in
court she just needs the funds to do it
now I got in touch with her I told her I
could get her the funds to go get her
son but that I would need some
documentation to verify that she's not
making this up she sent me the original
police report the child recovery order
from a court in Malawi and records from
the Ministry of Foreign Affairs in
Malawi and Interpol and the ministry of
external Affairs in India and the
national Human Rights Commission in
India she's definitely not making this
up but she has to fight the case
in India so if a bunch of us chip in we
can send Roma to India and cover her
legal expenses so that she can get her
son back
I have to say
of all the really awesome things we have
an opportunity to do at some point in
life
helping a kidnapped child get back to
his mother is pretty high up there
there's a link in the description box if
you can please send some support to Roma
and let's all pray that this story has a
happy ending